over the last year we've seen a crazy
spike in the price of solana more than a
hundred x i'm not particularly
interested in price movements and never
give financial advice on this channel
but i still wanted to answer the
question is there something different
about solana or is this just another
overhyped crypto project solana is now
one of the largest cryptocurrencies in
the world and supporters of the project
will tell you that it all comes down to
the speed of the solana network bitcoin
can process about seven transactions per
second ethereum is capable of almost
double that but solana boasts that the
network can handle over 50 000
transactions per second that's more than
the entire visa credit card network and
the solana team claims they can go even
further whenever i hear about a
breakthrough like this i immediately
think trade off if speeding up a network
was as easy as changing a few lines of
code everyone would just do it so the
solana team must be thinking about
things differently so let's walk through
the common trade-offs in blockchain
development as well as the history of
solana so that we can make up our own
minds about this project
blockchain users don't only care about
how many transactions can be processed
at the same time they also care about
how quickly those transactions settle
ethereum approves transactions every 15
seconds while bitcoin takes 10 minutes
solana on the other hand is settling
every 400 milliseconds for some users
this is really important but everything
comes with a cost so what are solana
users sacrificing in favor of speed well
it's certainly not fees bitcoin and
ethereum are notorious for high
transaction fees and it wouldn't be
crazy to think that a faster network
would cost more to use that's certainly
true for most services but blockchains
are a little bit different while bitcoin
transactions can cost the equivalent of
several dollars to complete and ethereum
can cost more than a hundred dollars
during peak times solana transactions
cost only a fraction of a penny right
now so if solana is faster and you
aren't paying more where's the catch
well it comes down to something called
the blockchain trilemma and it's
actually pretty straightforward
essentially in the world of crypto there
is a three-way trade-off between
decentralization security and
scalability traditionally you can only
choose two most blockchains optimize for
decentralization meaning that there's no
one central point of control that needs
to be trusted and security meaning that
the blockchain will operate as expected
and won't get hacked but in this
scenario you have to sacrifice
scalability meaning that high volumes of
transactions will slow the network down
this is the case with the bitcoin
network where millions of computers
around the world verify the integrity of
every transaction it's a remarkably
resilient system and it's the gold
standard for decentralization but it's
not very fast the same proof-of-work
mining system that enables its high
degree of decentralization and security
also means that every transaction
requires tons of processing power and
inhibits the scale of the network one
good example of a different approach to
the blockchain trilemma is the binance
smart chain which was created by the
cryptocurrency exchange of the same name
this blockchain is capable of around 60
transactions per second which is faster
than both bitcoin and ethereum and it
has low fees but it isn't very
decentralized most of the computers that
validate the network are controlled by
binance so you have to trust them just
as you would a traditional bank
wrestling with the blockchain trilemma
has been the focal point of many crypto
projects over the last few years debates
have been raging in the crypto community
over which project might actually create
a new model with some real value but
there has never been a really clear
winner it's still very early in crypto
generally but solana has attracted a lot
of developers to their ecosystem so they
must have found a solution that at least
feels right to certain people
conversations about crypto usually go
one of two ways pure speculation about
prices or complex analysis of algorithms
this video is going to be neither of
those instead i'm going to focus on the
actual human being behind the solana
project anatoly yakovenko as you've
probably gleaned from my other videos i
firmly believe that the right founder
can move mountains to make science
fiction a reality by sheer force of will
so it's the human stories that i really
like to focus on anatoly is a solid
low-level engineer who spent 13 years
working at the semiconductor company
qualcomm while he was there he wrote
software that now runs on hundreds of
millions of mobile devices before
android and ios were the most popular
mobile operating systems many phones ran
what's called the binary runtime
environment for wireless or brew for
short back in the early 2000s nearly
every feature phone ran brew
although it was often rebranded to look
like it was developed by verizon or at t
anatoly wrote code for brew that
interfaced directly with the hardware in
the phone and this is incredibly complex
work back then phones weren't very
powerful and resources like memory and
cpu cycles were extremely limited in
order to win on performance anatoly's
team at qualcomm had to be as efficient
as possible to really squeeze every bit
of speed out of these limited chips it
was hard work but it taught him how to
write hyper-efficient software which
clearly shaped his thinking about
designing solana even while anatoly was
at qualcomm he was playing around with
cryptocurrency at one point he even
considered getting into bitcoin mining
but he hit a bit of a funny stumbling
block when he went to order the proper
equipment there was a company that
promised an asic for bitcoin mining and
they built it but they mined with it for
six months before they gave it to anyone
that pre-ordered that like showed me
what crypto's all about don't trust
anyone
after a long career at qualcomm and then
a short stint at a distributed system
startup anatoly joined dropbox he
wouldn't stay long though this was 2017
and he had become obsessed with crypto
during the most recent wave of hype
prices were spiking and ethereum had
just broken 20 billion dollars in market
cap everyone was talking about a
breakthrough moment for crypto and
several ethereum competitors started to
emerge a few of these were direct copies
of the ethereum code base but anatoly
didn't think that was a winning strategy
instead he was thinking about how
decentralized blockchains could one day
replace centralized exchanges like the
nasdaq modern stock exchanges are some
of the highest throughput systems in the
world with servers regularly executing
tens of thousands of transactions per
second a big part of why stock exchanges
remain fast and relatively fair is
precisely because they are centralized
the point of crypto is to have true
decentralization and the projects that
succeed will be the projects that
achieve that everyone trusts the
exchanges to put each participant on a
level playing field and so far they have
when stock traders deploy code to
interact with the new york stock
exchange that code can wind up running
on any one of many servers in the
exchange data center the problem is that
if your server is a little bit closer to
the central server you could wind up
with a speed advantage so the nyse
connects every single server with a
cable of the exact same length 185 yards
this level of control is only possible
in centralized systems so the idea of
running something like the nasdaq or the
nyse on a blockchain was seen as a crazy
idea but anatoly formulated a solution
by going back to the early days of radio
the networks that power traditional
radio had a problem when they first came
online if two stations tried to transmit
on the same channel simultaneously it
would create static radio engineers
eventually solved the problem by placing
clocks at every radio station and then
coordinating exact times when each
station was allowed to transmit google
actually uses something similar to
synchronize its global data center
network every google server farm has an
atomic clock which allows it to stay in
sync with other server farms around the
world the bitcoin and ethereum networks
don't have built-in clocks so their
validators need to spend considerable
resources to figure out the correct
order of transactions anatoly realized
that if he added a timestamp to each
transaction he could speed things up
considerably he called this technology
which is now the core building block of
solana proof of history the math behind
this particular piece of solana is
fairly complex so if you want to learn
more i'll leave a link to some resources
in the description but for now the
important takeaway is that proof of
history allows each validator to work
faster instead of waiting for consensus
from the other validators in the network
blocks can be approved independently
provided that the timestamp is correct
in order to build the initial founding
team for solana anatoly reached out to
former colleagues from qualcomm this was
a smart move since building solana would
require some remarkably complex
low-level programming but the founding
team weren't just great programmers they
also seem like incredibly intense people
generally just look at the fact that
four out of the five solana co-founders
have completed an ironman triathlon this
has clearly led to a fast-paced work
environment which is important because
they are competing against tons of other
projects in the crypto space right now
even though solana is now worth billions
anatoly launched the project with a
pretty conventional seed round he raised
a little over 3 million dollars in
exchange for roughly 16 of the total
amount of soul tokens this deal now
stands as one of the best investments of
all time since the investors have made
close to a one million percent return in
just a few years the speed of
developments in crypto is really
staggering now that three million
dollars didn't last very long so anatoly
raised another 20 million dollars in
three subsequent rounds and those
investors have also done incredibly well
even still things didn't always go
smoothly
2018 marked the start of a crypto winter
and the price of bitcoin fell more than
65 percent this led to a few funds
bailing on their planned solana
investments at the last minute there was
a silver lining for the solana team
though bear markets are great for
washing out speculators and people who
just want to get rich quick after prices
collapsed the only people still working
were genuinely passionate about crypto
and in it for the long term anatoly and
his team spent two years basically fully
heads down they didn't really talk to
the media or try to promote their
project at all they just stayed laser
focused on building great software
reliability was top of mind no one was
going to use an unstable blockchain no
matter how fast it was when they first
launched their test network with 40
validators it immediately crashed and
took multiple hours to restore they
eventually got the system working though
and were able to launch the beta version
of the solana main net in march of 2020.
this wound up being perfect timing since
stimulus checks were just about to hit
bank accounts and lots of people were
starting to worry about inflation which
drove them to take a deeper look at
crypto it wasn't just the crypto bull
run that helped solana become a top five
cryptocurrency though after all plenty
of new projects have come and gone in
that time while they were able to ride
this new crypto wave it was their
community of developers that kept them
from wiping out but every project tries
to build a vibrant community so how did
solana actually pull it off well it all
comes down to building a high quality
self-custody user experience that means
making it easy for people who own solana
to move it out of the exchange where
they might have bought it and into a
wallet where they can take it anywhere
most cryptocurrency users still store
all of their assets in centralized
exchanges this is usually fine because
it means that they don't have to deal
with installing a wallet storing private
keys or accidentally sending funds to
the wrong address this works for lots of
people but it doesn't really align with
solana's long-term vision anatoly
estimates that only about 30 million
crypto users self-custody their crypto
holdings and that's across the entire
industry that's really small compared to
the most popular internet services these
days remember facebook has nearly 3
billion users as with any crypto project
there are multiple options when it comes
to how to interact with the blockchain
the most popular wallet for solana right
now is phantom and it's growing so
quickly that usage of the phantom wallet
broke one million users just seven
months after it launched now we saw
something similar happen with ethereum
back when metamask launched in 2016 and
there are a ton of similarities between
phantom and metamask but metamask users
are increasingly running into high fees
on the ethereum network and solana
doesn't have this problem these low fees
have enabled solana to stake a claim in
the nft marketplace with new projects
launching every day and costing next to
nothing to mint but nfts are just one
small part of the decentralized
financial system and an increasing
number of defy applications are being
built on solana the key metric to watch
here is hackathon attendance solana's
first hackathon had one thousand
participants the second had over three
thousand and the third broke thirteen
thousand these hackathons helped
introduce developers to the solana
ecosystem and have already led to the
launch of 400 different solana related
projects these projects are all testing
new ideas in a variety of industries
there's a music service called audies a
gaming project called star atlas and of
course a ton of financial services
developers clearly love the fact that
solana is so fast and cheap but if we go
back to the blockchain trilemma from
earlier we still need to discuss
decentralization this is a major
sticking point when people discuss
solana and conversations tend to get
heated quickly whenever money is at
stake add to the fact that
decentralization is not a single metric
but instead a broad collection of
decisions and you'll quickly find tons
of differing opinions on the topic one
common way to analyze the
decentralization of a blockchain is to
look at how many nodes on the network it
would take to grab full control in a
perfect scenario you would need
thousands of people all coming together
but in reality most blockchains have a
handful of powerful organizations that
orchestrate the majority of the mining
and validating the number of entities
that you need to compromise in order to
take control is called the nakamoto
coefficient and it's actually pretty
good on solana currently at 19 but
detractors are quick to point out that
the real control comes from ownership of
the actual soul tokens control the
tokens and you control the validators
and 48 of these tokens are controlled by
quote unquote insiders with another 30
percent set aside for ecosystem
development fans of other blockchains
hate this because it's yet another form
of centralization but i do think this
can be overcome with time as the solana
team distributes tokens to the community
their proportional control will decline
and eventually team members and initial
investors will sell tokens on the open
market to diversify their holdings it
won't happen overnight but it'll be
interesting to see if the critiques of
solana change as tokens become more
evenly distributed overall i think
solana is so interesting because it
feels like a project that was
tailor-made to refute the common
criticisms of blockchains for years tons
of people have been saying that
decentralization isn't important and
blockchains are slow and expensive
solana is the perfect counter example to
those arguments because it's fast cheap
and not overly focused on
decentralization in the short term it
seems like the solana team is making the
right trade-offs at least in terms of
attracting developers and building new
applications it seems reasonable that
there might be a world where people
would accept more centralization in the
short run if there's a light at the end
of the tunnel and they can experiment
freely without worrying about high fees
but let me know what you think in the
comments have you used any defy
applications do you like solana i'm
looking forward to digging more into
crypto and web3 projects in the future
but in the meantime please check out
this recommended video the youtube
algorithm thinks you'll really like it
[Music]